das hier ist das sechste Video der
siebenteiligen Interviewserie mit den
Teilnehmern von Seven vs world Staffel 2
viel Spaß mit dem Interview von Nova
und bevor es losgeht entschuldigt bitte
die schlechte Audioqualität und ist
leider eine Datei kaputt gegangen
weswegen wir mit dieser Qualität
Vorlieben nehmen müssen der drop off war
in dieser Staffel deutlich extremer
erzähl uns bitte wie der Tag für dich
abgelaufen ist und wie du ihn
wahrgenommen hast ja
gezogen
beim Start sozusagen ja hat jemand
irgendwie
[Musik]
als Teilnehmer aber super viel irgendwie
so schon probiert rauszufinden okay weil
wir wissen ja gar nichts
kommt da vielleicht so und dann durch
diese Krankheit okay es ist viel Staffel
1 wir fahren im Boot raus jeder zieht
sich nackt aus packt seine Sachen
so ja und dann kommen Flugzeug
ja das war auf jeden Fall eine sehr
große Überraschung und keiner muss
richtig so was jetzt genau passiert und
dann wurden wir eingeteilt sind
hochgeflogen und ab da war mal irgendwie
einfach voll in dem Film drin also da
bist über die ganze Insel geflogen
unterhalten Sie die komplette grüne
Hölle so das war richtig krass und dann
diese also das adrenal wenn wirklich
mein Herz so richtig klopfen das ist
dann wie sehr Quinoa springen jetzt raus
das war echt richtig krass und besonders
wertlose kompletten Klamotten an da also
ich habe Handschuhe an meine
Wanderstiefel so ich war komplett
bekleidet ich hatte noch meine
Regenjacke unterwarnung mein gut so
einen anderen hat doch eine GoPro so für
die schönen Aufnahmen dann auch noch und
ja bin da halt reingesprungen halt ich
wusste gar nicht was mich erwartet ich
habe auch das eingeschätzt dass ich so
ganz andere Probleme haben werde vor Ort
also beispielsweise Wassergewinnung habe
ich mir übelst den Kopf drüber gemacht
und
so ja eventuell Salzwasser
disziplinieren Plastikflaschen sammeln
sonst irgendwie was so
Kokosnusswasser ich hatte meinen
Wasserfilter ja auch dabei ja und das
war gar kein Problem also das ich hatte
glücklicherweise Süßwasserquelle aber es
war super spannend weil einfach manche
Probleme waren übermäßig gar nicht
Gedanken gemacht hat und dann andere
Probleme die man als so fast schon
gelöst irgendwie erachtet so die waren
halt wichtiger struggle so also es war
was wären Beispiel für so ein Problem
oder was war dein größtes Problem in den
Tagen also für mich persönlich das
größte Problem Isolation 100%, also das
hätte ich nie so erwartet dass ein dass
du so sehr mitnimmt und das sein dass so
also mich besonders als Mensch was
willst du vielleicht wenigstens so
rückwirkend betrachtet auch vielleicht
Sinn ergibt ich bin sehr sozialer Mensch
so wenn man mir halt diese Komponente
nimmt und auch so ich bin super Famil
und das ist so ein Beispiel dessen dass
ich nicht erwartet hätte dass vier Tage
ohne menschlicher Kontakt dass mich das
so an meinen Limit bringt dass ich
wirklich
also das ist nicht mehr gegen das ist
wirklich so schlimm war dass ich so
wirklich Panikattacken bekommen habe und
das hätte ich nicht ich hätte mit so
vielen anderen Dingen gerechnet mit
Krokodilen Schlangen Spinnen sonst
irgendwie was aber das ist dann am
Endeffekt einfach leider Fakt ist dass
ich mit Isolation dass wir das viel zu
viel war ich auch nicht gedacht so muss
man erst mal erfahren und das dann so
als wäre das gerade eben schon
angedeutet verrückte Dinge gefunden zu
haben was war so das Verrückteste was du
gefunden hast ja das war ich weiß nicht
es war auf jeden Fall ein
säugetierknochen der noch Fleisch oben
dran hatte und der Knochen wurden so
rausgeguckt hat und der Knochen war
schon so richtig weil das schon so lange
her war und es war so ziemlich widerlich
weil ich gedacht habe so es war auch
echt großer Durchmesser also es muss ich
weiß nicht was das gewesen ist also es
muss irgendein großes Säugetier sein was
da anscheinend irgendwie von irgendeinem
Meeresbewohner es war schon widerlich
ich habe Flip Flops in allen Box auch
ultra viel gefunden allen möglichen
Sorten Autositze
Drucker ich habe eine Drucker gefunden
alten Einzelteilen wo ich dann ein Teil
auf der rechten Seite der Eintritt auf
der linken Seite gefunden habe also
wirklich ganz folgt auch teilweise so
aus so Schaumstoff so Zeitungen die
Kinder in der Grundschule machen will
das war dann irgendwie so ein spanischer
Name ich weiß nicht mehr genau und hat
sich genau lesen was abgeblättert war so
eine Polizei sind Sheriff Ding oder so
also so Kindersachen Halt und ich habe
Fußball gewonnen mir ist es für dich
jetzt wieder in der Zivilisation zu sein
freust du dich bist du wehmütig
abgebrochen zu haben wie geht es dir
allgemein mit der Entscheidung also der
Moment an dem ich so für mich selbst
entschieden habe so ich drücke die Knopf
jetzt ich kann nicht mehr war richtig
hart und ich habe da auch klar geweint
weil ich so erleichtert war aber
andererseits auch einfach war ich auch
so enttäuscht irgendwie von mir selbst
und war so das ist doch jetzt nicht wahr
und ich wollte halt die sieben Tage so
krass durchziehen und war für mich war
das richtig schwer und ich war teilweise
auch super enttäuscht von mir selbst ein
paar sauer aber habe halt auch einfach
realisiert so ist geht nicht mehr so ich
muss jetzt abbrechen und
was war richtig schlimm war wirklich
eine hin und her aber ich bin umso
dankbarer jetzt wieder ich meine ich bin
keine weil das ist nicht mein Content
und ich habe mich trotzdem mit der
Aufgabe bestellt und ich habe es
trotzdem gemacht und klar ich bin jetzt
zum vierten Tag gekommen aber ich glaube
dafür muss ich mich jetzt selber nicht
irgendwie Strafen oder da ist irgendwie
sauer auf mich sein so ich habe es
versucht so und da jeder hat auch andere
Grenzen so da war meine
und genau
ich schätze auch teilweise Sachen
irgendwie Wert die hier einfach eine
Normalität so eine Dusche das war so
schön
das war ich habe davon geträumt dass ich
duschen gehen darf also solche Sachen so
Kleinigkeiten einfach die man einfach
wertschätzt für mich auch noch mal so
dass ich auch so dankbar bin dass ich so
und ihm das Umfeld habe dass ich so
gerne mag und die auch gehört haben und
so ja und dass ich nie wieder im Leben
so lange
werden möchte an Tag 3 hat das ja
angefangen richtig stark zu Gewittern
wie war das für dich so etwas ohne
Schutz zum ersten mal hautnah
mitzuerleben also das unwetterantrag 3
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht wie die anderen ist aber
ich denke ich war auch so geschockt ob
ich es war ist er wirklich sehr gruselig
besonders so man kennt ja so
Tropenstürme und sowas irgendwie
Vermögen sehen aber sowas mal selber
mitzuerleben deshalb so ein krasses
Gewitter mal ist man halt eigentlich
ausgeliefert ist bei mir halt auch noch
in Kombination dann dass ich am Strand
war ganz oben und das halt die Ebbe bzw
die Flut angestiegen ist anstatt den
Tagen davor deswegen halt auch mein
ganzes Shelter zusammengekracht ist über
mir jetzt geschlafen habe und sowas das
war schon also da hatte ich schon echt
Angst wirklich in mein lieber gesagt so
und habe immer so ein bisschen
rausgenommen die Welt geht unter also
das war schon echt ein schönes Gefühl
für die Natur Gewalten so ausgesetzt zu
sein ich habe vielleicht einfach mal
gewünschten Haus zu haben
was nimmst du Positives für dich aus dem
Projekt mit also in den vier Tagen habe
ich für mich auf jeden Fall
gelernt oder so mitgenommen dass
ich sowas machen kann und dass ich mich
auch also dass ich die Challenge halt
auch angenommen habe und das war für
mich schon mal so ein krasses learning
einfach so diesen Mut zu haben Sachen zu
tun und halt auch der Grund wie gesagt
meines Ausstiegs dass ich halt ein
unendlich sozialer Mensch bin und dass
ich das einfach für mein Leben auch
einfach brauche und das wäre mir das
fehlt dass ich so nicht existieren kann
und ich möchte nie wieder in meinem
Leben 4 Tage isoliert sein das sind auch
mitgenommen aber was für eine schöne
Erfahrung ich bin überhaupt nicht
rausgewachsen und auch wenn für andere
Grenzen wo anders und ich habe sie halt
trotzdem ja bis dahin ausgereizt ich
glaube das
würdest du deinen besten Freunden so
eine Erfahrung wünschen oder sogar
empfehlen
empfehlen würde ich das tendenziell
glaube ich nie machen wenn ich ehrlich
bin
gehe jetzt auch schon sagen so ja also
ich hätte das aber anders gemacht und
ich hätte bis 7 Tage absolut
durchgehalten und blablabla und die
blonde schwingto blablabla aber ehrlich
zu sein also ich glaube niemand ist sich
bewusst wie krass das war und
auch wenn man so die erste Staffel
geschaut hat und das jetzt so von außen
mitbekommt da wirklich vor Ort zu sein
wenn man sieht ja auch selbst in der
Ausstattung oder immer nur kurz Moment
aber vier also bei mir vier Tage
komplett
du sitzt da mein Entertainment von hi
ich habe mir doch auch krass dass mein
Abend Entertainment hi der von A nach B
schwimmen also es war wirklich eine
unglaublich krasse Erfahrung wenn die
richtig geisteskrank seid dann macht das
so haut rein aber ich persönlich
muss sagen und ich erhalte eigentlich
schon viel aus
ja aber was war toll war schwanger aber
wir sind eine Empfehlung würde ich jetzt
nicht aussprechen vielen Dank herzlichen
Glückwunsch für deine Leistung und viel
Spaß zurück in der Zivilisation endlich
in den verdienten Feierabend
[Musik]